Welcome to Academy Dialogues.
My name is Shawn Finnie.
I am honored to guide
this conversation today
with three individuals
that I believe
are shaping our
culture through film,
and that is writer-director Gina
Prince-Bythewood, Oscar winner
TJ Martin, and the incomparable,
incredible Delroy Lindo.
Welcome, everybody.
Thank you.
First, I mean, when we say
it's good to see you now,
it just takes on a
whole new level based
on where we are in the world.
So first, I want
to just check in.
How are you doing?
Gina, we can start with you.
How are you managing
in this time?
It's so funny because
that's my go to is
to you say, how are you?
And it's such a loaded question.
Yeah, it's a very
scary time right now.
A couple weeks ago, I was saying
that it felt like a hopeful
time, given that it felt that
true change was finally coming,
that in this moment, instead
of people being defensive,
people were finally
understanding
what we've been fighting for
all these years and hearing us.
But right now, I've gone back
to it feeling like a scary time.
And I think what's
indicative is my son, who's
19, get pulled over by
police for the first time.
When?
When, Gina?
Yeah, when was your
son pulled over?
Two days ago.
Wow.
And the fact that my
husband I didn't even
have the luxury of being
able to be angry at him
for getting a speeding ticket.
Our first question
was are you OK?
And then, he survived it.
And the fact that that's where
our mind goes is pretty insane.
Wow.
And Delroy, I know you also
have a son, so I'm sure when--
19, I have a 19-year old, yeah.
So when you hear that as a
creative, but also as a human
and as a parent, how does
that register with you?
What Gina just said?
Yeah, what Gina just said.
First of all, the fact
that Gina acknowledged
that it is a loaded question--
and it is.
And it's loaded
from my standpoint
because it is chock full of
so many potential responses
that one could have to the
question, how are you doing?
One can respond in any number
of different directions.
When I hear Gina saying that
her 19-year-old was pulled over,
and my 19-year-old has been
pulled over and was also--
he wrecked his car a few
months ago in a car wreck.
Well, no, he wrecked his car.
He's fine.
But I really relate to the
various responses that one has.
Are you OK?
It happened at 3:00
in the morning.
My lady ended up
going to where he was.
Thank god somebody
had stopped, a brother
had stopped and stayed with
him until my lady and a law
enforcement officer got there.
It happened that
the law enforcement
officer was reasonable,
a reasonable human being.
So all of that was positive.
But you know what?
I think the most honest
or authentic thing
that I can say in terms of
responding to that question
is that there is a--
I don't want to say a
deadening of responses,
of emotional
responses, but there
is a blunting of responses,
just because there are
so many responses that one has.
To your question, how am I
doing, in context of everything
that's going on, I'm doing
OK and probably-- no,
not probably, better than OK
because I'm working right now.
Millions of people
are not, as we know.
I am able to, therefore, because
I'm working, support my family.
That is an extraordinary,
almost a luxury in these times.
So I am constantly
attempting to take a half
a step back from my present
and try at least to figure out
perspective.
So there are these multi
steps that one takes.
And so--
That's the most honest, and
thank you for the honesty.
And I feel like this
Academy Dialogues,
this whole thing was created
to give our members a platform
to speak their truth
and to talk about all
of the issues and things that
are happening in the community
as it relates to art
and as it just relates
to the human experience.
TJ, how are you--
I would like to add one more
thing before you go to TJ.
And not to dwell on
this, and perhaps
we can discuss it later
in the conversation
if it comes back
around, but when
Gina said a few weeks ago
she was feeling hopeful,
my response was why?
And I respond that
way not as a challenge
to Gina or anybody else,
but I'm curious about--
I find myself being curious
about what are the components?
What were the components
of your hopefulness
weeks or months
ago, whenever it was
it you were feeling hopeful?
And what are the
components that have
caused your current response?
Because that's a whole other
series of conversations.
But again, I just
wanted to mention that.
We can definitely
go to that right
after this, right after TJ.
Yeah, yeah.
TJ, how are you?
As everyone pointed out, it's
a weighted question, right?
If I'm going to be completely
honest, I'm processing, right?
In active processing, I
think there's a wide range
of emotions that come with it.
I think for me,
in terms of like--
I have a tremendous amount
of anxiety right now.
Part of that probably is in
a really practical manner.
I'm in between
projects, so I tend
to process through the
work, and it brings my mind
at ease to be able to
actually take that energy,
and package it, and
put it in a direction.
And without that,
the ups and downs
are very visceral
and palpable for me.
And I don't think it's
because of necessarily that--
it's not because things
have fundamentally
changed by any means.
It's that the flaws of this
country, just the window,
the curtains have been opened.
And the curtains are open.
I'm appalled by the
inability to actually
have an empathetic
conversation about who
we are as a community.
And that, I find
really unnerving.
Even with this kind of really
diverse coalition of allies
and what allyship
looks like in 2020,
the blowback is
equally discouraging.
And I find that we're
all processing out loud
on our social media feeds.
We're all processing internally.
And I don't necessarily think
we're having healthy dialogue.
I think this is why this is
so important because I think
it is one of the few forums
where you can actually
have a healthy dialogue.
To Delroy's point, there's
not one dominant emotion.
It's minute-to-minute,
day-by-day, hour-by-hour,
at least for me.
I had a ton of
anxiety this morning.
And then by noon, I spoke.
I did a webinar with a bunch
of young filmmakers at USC,
specifically Black women,
that are doing projects,
nonfiction projects as a result
of the current civil unrest.
A lot of products are
motivated by that,
and that brought
me a ton of ease.
And then, now, I feel good.
And then by tonight, maybe
I'll be tripping again.
It's an ongoing dialogue with
myself and the world, right?
I mean, the most honest way you
said that is processing, right?
Which means you're
neither here nor there.
You're in transition.
And going back to what
Delroy mentioned earlier,
we talk a lot about change,
the need for change, change,
change.
But in order for
things to change,
something has to have changed.
And so to your point, Delroy,
when you were asking Gina,
and you were saying you
were feeling hopeful before,
what gave you that hope, Gina?
What brought you to that point,
to Delroy's question earlier?
I feel that it was
a couple things.
I mean, it was certainly,
as TJ just mentioned,
the allyship felt
different this time.
It didn't feel simplistic.
It felt that there were true
allies coming out and putting
themselves in harm's
way in the way
that we've had to by
ourselves within the--
Kamala being chosen
was a big deal.
Watching the
Democratic Convention
made me feel hope
about what could be.
And then within our
industry, to finally
have conversations with
people that I've worked with
and had those hard
conversations.
One in particular-- why do I
need to walk into your offices
and not pass one Black person
from the reception desk
all the way to
your corner office?
And for the first time
people not being defensive,
but actually accepting that they
have messed up in a big way,
and having a certainty about
changing it, and knowing
why it needed to be changed.
And then the other
thing was there
are so many collectives
of Black artists
coming together from
all of it, from acting,
directing, producing,
below the line.
We're all coming together
in such a big way
for the first time and
seeing and understanding
and feeling our power.
And that has felt really
good because we've never
done that before.
But I think the thing
that changed for me--
and it's been a
slow grind back--
this kid, this 17-year-old
kid who killed the protesters,
and the fact that
he is being excused
by the White House and others.
I cannot wrap my head around how
far we have fallen as a country
when that is happening.
And from that point on, it
does seem, as TJ mentioned,
that we've got this
great allyship.
But the blowback is starting
to feel even stronger.
And I just know
the fight that we
are in in this moment,
literally for survival.
When you're talking about
the community aspect,
I resonated because in
our community, like you
said before, maybe we weren't
as collaborative before
or weren't working
together as closely.
And for all of you, are you
noticing that change as we
go to the younger generation?
Are you noticing that they're
wanting to work together more?
And what can we learn
from that, if so?
Well, I work in nonfiction,
and our crews are not as big.
And my creative
partner and I, we
do a lot of the
heavy lifting, like
from shooting to
cutting to everything.
But when we're working
the commercial space,
we're obviously bigger crews.
I still think there's--
no pun intended-- but there's an
old guard within the industry.
I think there's a tremendous
amount of nepotism.
And even for a
younger generation
that has a vision for how
they want to participate
in the industry, I
still think they're
met with some really
rigid blockades.
And I think like a
lot of people, right?
That becomes an
opportunity to mold
how you want to
handle that and how
you want to integrate yourself.
And then once you
integrate yourself,
what do you do once
you integrate yourself
within the confines
of the industry,
even though it's a
day-to-day organized chaos.
But I think the thing
that I am encouraged by
is, like any institution,
it's unfortunate,
but it's also just
the way it is.
I find that there are younger
voices advocating for change
and forcing the hand of the
institution, AKA the industry,
to examine itself and
help facilitate change.
That's always been the case
within the institution.
It's always an outside force.
But I love the fact that at
least younger voices are not
dropping the ball
in that regard.
And that, I find
really encouraging,
and I want to collaborate
with those people.
We talk about,
often, Nina Simone
has this quote, how
can you be an artist
and not reflect
the times, right?
And we talk about
that responsibility.
And I wanted to ask you all,
and Delroy, starting with you,
is it the artist's
responsibility alone,
or is it a collaboration
with the system,
with the industry, with
that it is in your opinion?
What do I think about that?
I think that, obviously, it is
a very personal and intimate
choice that one
makes for oneself.
But my personal
response to the question
is that, yes, I do
feel a responsibility.
But I want to say that--
and this goes back to
something you said, Shawn,
at the beginning of
the conversation--
having to do with I think
I'm a human being first.
Yes.
For any other definitions,
descriptives, definitions,
I'm a human being first.
And I want to say
first and foremost.
So I think I'm always
responding as a human being,
albeit that at a
certain point, I
am filtering my responses
through the conduit
of my creative self.
But going back to
when we were talking
about our kids,
our 19-year-olds.
I'm responding as a parent
period, period the end.
That's it-- no more and no less.
So to answer your question,
personally, yes, I
feel a responsibility.
But I think I am not defining my
various responses as an artist.
I think I'm defining
my responses
as a human being on the planet.
Does that make sense?
That makes all of the
sense of the world.
TJ, I would say to you,
following up with that,
how does that impact the
way that you approach film?
We saw you won the Oscar
for Undefeated, which
follows a Memphis football team
having a over 100-year losing
streak.
And that power of
them seeing themselves
as that and then what happened
when you came into it,
how did that affect
your approach to coming
into working with them?
How did it affect my
approach in terms of?
In terms of you're working with
the power of imagery, right?
You're working with a
team who sees themselves
as losers for about 100
years, and the decision
to highlight that and
how that inversely
changed the power of how they
saw themselves because they
ended up winning after that.
Well, they did not
win the-- well,
I'd be giving my
part of the movie.
But in the season
that we covered,
they still were in
a losing streak.
So the challenge
with Undefeated was
that when you do a
verite film, you're
trying to express to the
audience, at least the way
my filmmaking partner and I see
it, the emotional experience
that you have.
Because we embedded ourselves
with this high school football
team in North Memphis for
the kids the senior year
of the first group of students
that came in and reshaped
the program with this
gentleman named Bill Courtney,
who was the coach.
The way with which the
students see themselves,
we can't take credit for that.
That's very much Bill
and the volunteers
that created a program that
were committed to the students
and to the student athletes
and were not doing it
for selfish purposes,
but rather that the coach
had moved to North Memphis.
He moved his business
there, and as a result,
he wanted to give
back to the community,
so he was a permanent
fixture of the community.
So the film can't
take credit for that.
But our job was to
go in and create--
can we capture the essence of
what the relationships were?
So a lot of the
biggest challenge
with Undefeated
in particular was
you've got a North Memphis,
which is 99.9% Black,
and you've got a white
coach, volunteer coach,
coming in from East Memphis.
And one of the things that
attracted us to the story
to begin with was
one of the players
was spending part his
time with the coaches
in East Memphis living
there throughout the week
and then living with his
grandmother in North Memphis
during the weekends.
And it was an opportunity to use
either this particular student
or the team's story to
explore race and class
and use this experience
as a reflection of how
we talk about race and
class in the country.
But then, the football
narrative itself
became so good
and so fascinating
that that's still present,
but through the conduit
of a football story.
But the bigger challenge
was I naturally
go into something
like that going like,
this particular coach, what
if he's got ulterior motives?
Is he giving the hard
sell on his relationship
with the students?
And the challenge after
spending time with them
was that there is a fundamental,
very real, very healthy
relationship between the
coach and the players.
Now, our job is to make
sure that we recognize
the blind spots in the baggage
that an audience is going
to come with that says is
this a white knight story,
which is a 100%
a valid question.
So how do we take that
and say, good analysis,
but if we take it a
step further and we
create themes that are a little
bit more about fatherhood,
you actually transcend that.
And that became a
challenge creatively,
but it was something that
was very necessary to get
a film for people to actually
look beyond race and class
and acknowledge it at the same
time, you know what I mean?
Because you're not
supposed to read it.
But then, can you say, oh, wow,
this is a real relationship.
And as a result, if we can get
that baggage out of the way,
then you're actually
looking at a coming
of age film, these
young men that
are transitioning from
end of high school
into the early
stages of manhood.
And that's really what the
film was about in a space
created by volunteers that
allowed them to be vulnerable,
and that was huge.
And this is slightly
tangential, but that
is one thing I find I'm
always attracted to,
which is so rarely seen
is finding spaces for men,
and particularly men of color,
and particularly Black men
to show their vulnerabilities
and feel comfortable
doing that.
So our job at that
point is to continue
to express to the audience
what we experienced
through the emotions of it and
through the storytelling of it,
and then preserve the
integrity of the space
and the vulnerability that
they gave us and allowed
us to capture in the
making of that film.
So I don't know if that
answers your question.
Gina, we were talking that
idea of the power of imagery
and this idea of self-identity.
And you've been open
about your childhood,
and growing up in
your community,
and really being the only
one or not really seeing
people who looked like you.
How did that affect the
way that you approach film?
I mean, it certainly
absolutely defines it,
knowing very early the
power of film and imagery.
Just in quick context--
adopted by a Salvadoran
mother and an Irish father
and raised and in,
really, an all-white area.
And so growing up, just
never seeing myself
reflected, not even
in my own family.
And that could do a number on
your self-esteem, certainly.
And thank god for sports,
which gave me the applause I
was so desperately craving.
But I remember distinctly
being 17 years old
and going to see the movie--
I forgot what movie
I was going to see,
but the trailer for She's
Gotta Have It came on.
And looking up there
at Nola Darling,
and am I like Nola, who she is?
No, but it was me
seeing someone who
looked like me up on that big
screen, and I was floored.
And I've never
forgotten that feeling.
And for me, from that
moment and knowing
that I wanted to tell
stories and get into film
and television that I wanted
to give an audience, especially
a Black audience, that
feeling that I had.
And so for me, my work has been
a fight to center our stories
and tell stories in every
genre, but through our lens.
And yeah, and I'm
the first audience,
so I'm writing
what I want to see.
And then my hope is then
that I can inspire and create
characters that we
can aspire to be.
And from there, the
world can see us
in all these different ways and
see the breadth of our humanity
and be inspired by us as well.
And when you spoke,
I've heard you
say that when you are
able to see yourself, then
you're able to see yourself.
And what that does and how it
can alter and change someone's
entire life--
I mean, obviously, the
opportunity and versatility,
right?
So when we're talking
about telling our stories
in Black cinema, while
also knowing that it
is for the larger audience.
It can be a Black story
and be universal as well.
Delroy, you've been
such a cultural icon
in a lot of Spike Lee's early
films and a staple, a staple
in the community in
what you mean to us.
And I've also seen
your versatility.
And just, there was a time, I
think, you weren't in filming.
You were just
performing in theater.
Have you always been able
to do that intersection?
Do you see us there in
theater to draw you to that?
Because you represent something
so magical in that space
as well.
First of all, were I am more
21st century individual,
I would have gone
on the internet
and looked up TJ and
Gina, and I did not.
Therefore, TJ, I did
not know that you--
that the film Undefeated,
which really moved me,
when you first--
I did not know that you were
involved with Undefeated.
So I want to say not only
congratulations to you
as an audience.
But an interesting
thing happened
when you first mentioned that
you are involved in that film.
I got goosebumps.
And the reason that
I got goosebumps
was because the depth of the
extent to which that film moved
me for a whole
variety of reasons.
So to the extent that
I gave Gina props,
I want to give you
props right now.
And if I were more
on the ball, I
would have looked it up before
we got on this interview,
and I would have led
with that, right?
That's one thing.
So props, man,
major props to you.
And Gina, when you were
speaking about your upbringing,
there were a couple of
aspects that I related to.
I was not formally adopted,
when I was very, very young,
I was taken in by a family that
were not my biological parents.
And I also spent a
very significant time
in my formative years
going to all-white schools
in all-white neighborhoods.
And so really, when
you started talking
about not seeing yourself
reflected back to yourself,
I get it 6000%.
But as it relates to
the making of work,
as I'm sitting here
listening to your narrative,
it occurred to me that what
happened with me is that
the aspects that I felt as
a young person and the pain,
deep-seated pain that was
visited on me as a result
of being a Black kid in
an all-white neighborhood,
a Black kid in all-white schools
and all that that comes with,
I have been able to use in
my work the individual--
the aloneness, the individual--
what's the word-- the
fact of feeling like one
is alone in the
world I have been
able to use really
constructively,
not without neuroses,
not without pain
and all the rest of that.
But in the final analysis, one
of the foundational aspects
of my career,
frankly, is the fact
that I have been able
to mine those things
for a creative good.
So I'm not quite sure
of what I'm saying other
than hearing you tell
your story, Gina, A,
inspired me, B, caused
me to reflect on myself.
And these are not reflections
I haven't had before,
but just seeing them in a
slightly different light.
And being able now
all these years later
to acknowledge, embrace how
the pain of my childhood,
I've been able to
use and utilize
as an adult. Like big
time, frankly, big time.
Is there a specific
role, Delroy,
that you were able to
really use that the most?
And continue using
it-- continue using it.
The other thing
I want to, I need
to add in the moment
is the fact I mentioned
at the beginning
of the conversation
that I feel extremely fortunate
that I am working, and I do.
And this goes, Shawn,
to your question
of how are you feeling?
Added to the fact
that I am working,
I'm working on a project
and the last project
that I did with Spike--
Spike's project and the project
that I'm working on currently
are both narratives in which
we, as African-descended people,
are front and center.
So the narrative is being
told very, very, very much
from our point of view.
And that enhances the
extent to which I feel--
and I'm sorry I'm going to use
this hackneyed and overused
word, but blessed because I am.
And the fact that these
projects are not--
we're in the middle
of-- we've just
started working on this film
that I'm doing right now,
so I don't know what the
finished result will be.
But what I can say
is that working
in the process of doing
this current work,
and absolutely working
in the process of having
made 5 Bloods, and the fact that
we were front and center is--
again, another hackneyed and
overused word-- but a gift.
That particularly now,
not only in the America
that we're living in, but the
world that we're living in,
the fact that I get to be a
part of these projects that
have nothing to do with
filtering through somebody
else's gaze or filtering through
somebody else's experience what
the story is, that's
an extraordinary thing.
And it does make, for
me, as a creative person,
as a human being
on the planet, it
makes a very profound and
positive difference to how
I negotiate my world with all
of its ugliness and the fact
that we, as African-descended
people, are being battered.
We are so much being
battered right now.
But as a human being, as a
human, as a creative person,
I have these islands,
these oases of affirmations
for who I am as an
African-descended person,
as a creative person, that
not only can I experience,
but then I can share with
the rest of the world, which
is extraordinary.
And it is said that in the
specific is the universal,
and you used the term,
the word universal earlier
in the conversation.
And I get to be a part of--
I've gotten the
gift of being a part
of very specifically
examining something
through the lens of who I
am as a Black individual,
sharing that with the world,
and hopefully affirming
the humanity, not the Black
humanity, the humanity
that exists in those journeys.
And that's extraordinary.
Beyond extraordinary.
I don't have the words to--
I mean, obviously,
there'd be no reason--
I had no idea about
your upbringing,
and that's so fascinating
to me because there's always
been a reason that I've
gravitated towards your work.
And in everything,
there is-- and I
know you just said humanity,
not Black humanity.
But for me, in every
role that you played,
you've always for me
represented Black manhood.
And it's not just
dignity and strength,
but this innate vulnerability
that might be from the way
that you grew up and the
things that you talked about.
But given that all
of those things
made a Black manhood for
me as opposed to so many
stereotypes that we're given.
And so I'm grateful
to you for that.
And you know I would say
congrats on Da 5 Bloods,
but it's really your
whole body of work
has always been
that for me, so it's
fascinating to hear where
some of that has come from.
Thank you.
We're talking a lot about
owning your stories, which
is what I captured from what
you were saying, Delroy,
is as being in the forefront
and behind the scenes narrating,
and showing and
sharing our stories
and how important it is to have
that authentic through line,
as well as documenting
our stories.
TJ, You've documented
LA 92, which
has been a story and a
staple in our community.
Talk to me about LA 92, and
what you've learned about that,
and where you think
we are right now,
and if there is
any change at all.
Yeah, for those who
haven't seen LA 92,
it's a film about the
civil unrest commonly known
as kind of the
Rodney King riots,
but I prefer civil unrest.
In '92, after Rodney King
was beaten by four motorists
and nearly murdered and then--
sorry, beaten by four cops
and nearly murdered,
and then the cops
getting off on the trial.
And then, it
became, to this day,
the most violent,
monetarily speaking,
the most violent civil
unrest in American history.
The project was
made in preparation
for the 25-year
anniversary of the unrest.
And we knew that
there was going to be
a number of films coming out.
We did not conceive
of the project.
It was a production company that
came up with the idea, sold it
to a network, and they
wanted us to direct it,
and they sent over a sizzle.
And in the sizzle, they'd
mined some other early archive.
And there was a moment in
the sizzle where there's
a gentleman from
South Central that
was captured on film
within his own community.
And he's waving a
hammer around, and he's
yelling at the top of his lungs,
and he's very, very emotional,
and he's crying.
He had just been looted.
And he's basically yelling
around within his community,
why steal from me?
I come from the ghetto too.
You call this activism.
You see a man falling
apart on the camera.
And for us, the vulnerability
in that particular moment
was the impetus of
the approach, which
is can you tell these
events only using archive,
and preserve the
integrity of the emotion
that people experienced
in that moment in time?
So can you create
an experiential film
and not one that's a
talking head documentary?
I find that,
oftentimes, when we're
looking at critical
moments in our history,
because it's happened
and because there's
a person giving analysis,
it creates a buffer
between the audience
and the experience
that fundamentally
changed people's lives.
This is a long
way of just saying
the film is a feature doc only
constructed out of archive.
And the idea is to create
an immersive experience
for audiences that may
have lived through it
or for younger audiences,
for younger generations that
don't know anything about it.
And we start the film
with a prologue of Watts.
And then, at the
end of the film,
it gets pretty
editorialized, where
we're intercutting
between '65 Watts,
the civil unrest in Watts,
and the civil unrest in '92.
And so the dominant
theme of the film
is that these
events are cyclical.
It's baked into a
system of violence
and a system of repression
that will never go away
until we actually are able to
have people in positions that
fundamentally hold the
reins of the system
change the system itself.
So to answer your question, what
am I seeing differently in 2020
is both on my social
media feed and in Twitter
and when things really
popped off in LA,
I was in the middle of
cutting our next film.
But I just couldn't resist.
I had to go down and experience
in real time what a protest
looks like during an epidemic.
It's a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity.
So in all three
instances, what I'm
seeing on my phone, what I'm
experiencing in person, what
I'm reading in the news,
the one stand-out thing is
the diverse coalition of faces
and what seems to be allyship
now, I think, is fundamentally
different than anything
we've ever seen.
And when I say diverse coalition
I don't mean Black and white.
I mean Latino, Asian-American,
Native representation,
all speaking out against
and for and on behalf
of the Black community,
actually showing true allyship
and empathy.
Because it felt like there is a
fundamental understanding that
when one member of our community
is attacked that we all suffer
as a result. And then we can
lift other communities up,
we are all going to
also benefit from it.
It's really simple,
and it's really clean.
However, having said that, that
is a fundamental difference.
But then, the part that I'm
a little bit more wary about
is because we do live in a
day and age where everyone
is almost a walking brand
through social media,
whatever it may be, is
Black pain, is that a fad?
And is it something that you
are speaking to your community
by showing support because
that is something that
is what you are supposed to do?
And then, what happens when
another Black man gets murdered
on camera, and then another, and
then another, and then another?
Does your does your
support fade away
because the dominant community
is no longer talking about it?
Does your support only
stop because you don't what
to do outside just
posting something?
That's right.
Yes.
So to answer your
question, there
is a fundamental change in terms
of what the allies look like.
I think it's too soon to
tell where we're going.
And as we talked
about earlier today,
I'm encouraged by,
especially the younger
voices and their actual very
active palpable participation.
I'm very much discouraged by
the growing blowback that's
creating even more
of a divisiveness
and our inability to have a
healthy, nuanced conversation
from different ideologies that
usually fundamentally want
the same things and
oftentimes just don't feel
like they're getting heard.
So I think the theme of
LA 92 is alive and well.
I think we're in a cycle,
a very violent cycle, which
is also just the
history of this country.
And I think what
happens next is--
I think only time will tell.
That's not to say don't
bow out from really trying
to have empathetic
conversations,
even with those that
disagree with you
because that's actually
what needs to happen.
Yeah.
We need to understand where
the vitriol and the hate
comes from for those
that, let's be honest--
I don't want to
stereotype, but oftentimes,
for people what feels
like they don't even
want people that
look like me or that
are darker than me to even
be in the same community,
in the same country.
I think what I hear you
saying is that we need
healing through conversation.
And in order to
have healing, there
has to be a space where
we can speak our truths.
And those truths
have to be heard.
It's not about you understanding
or agreeing with those truths.
It's just about we
need to be heard.
And when you speak
about where we
are in the industry in the
landscape of organizations
and companies and
Black Lives Matter,
I've never seen so many people
screaming Black Lives Matter
that are not Black right now.
And to your point, I'm
like, what does that mean?
And that brings
me to my question.
What is the role and
the responsibility
of an ally in your opinions?
What does that look like?
And knowing that allies
can show their advocacy
in different ways,
like you said TJ.
They can show and post
online, but is that a fad?
When we're no longer talking
about hashtag whoever,
is that gone?
What is the ideas of
the roles of allies?
Delroy, were you going
to say something?
Yeah.
That's the fundamental question.
What does alliance
truly look like?
And TJ, when you said
is Black pain a fad,
I think that is the subject,
the phenomenon, the thing
that people who
want to be allies
have to answer for themselves
so that it is not a fad.
And that brings me to a short
passage that I wanted to read,
I want to share, that
I just read recently.
You all live in Los
Angeles, is that true?
Mm-hmm, yeah.
Yeah.
OK.
The only reason I ask
that because I do not
live in Los Angeles.
And that doesn't make me better.
Just geographically,
it's connected
to what I'm about to read.
So the question-- and I'm
sorry if I sound like a college
lecturer right now--
but I want to ask, does
everybody on this call
know who Dijon Kizzee is?
It's Dijon Kizzee.
I hope I'm pronouncing
his name correctly.
No clue.
I didn't know who he who
he was either until I
read this article.
So just bear with me one second.
This is from the Sunday New
York Times of September 13, OK?
"In late August, Los
Angeles Sheriff's deputies
shot a Black man.
The Black man's name
is Dijon Kizzee,
whom they had stopped for a
suspected traffic violation
as he rode his bicycle.
He became the seventh
man killed by deputies
in Los Angeles since the death
of George Floyd in Minneapolis
on Memorial Day weekend.
On the same afternoon, state
legislators in Sacramento
raced to the end of
their 2020 session.
The most significant
police reform measure
heralded in the
days of the Black
Lives Matter marches that
filled the streets did not even
come up for a vote."
That, to me-- and
it's a longer article,
but just those opening
paragraphs, those opening two
paragraphs, are
profoundly indicative
of the potential fadism, as
you say, TJ, of Black pain.
The fact that none of us on
this call, myself included,
knew who Dijon Kizzee was--
is.
He stopped for a suspected
traffic violation
riding his bicycle and
the fact that the state
legislature clearly
knew nothing about this,
and it had no relationship
to whatever legislation was
on the books having to do
with potential police reform,
for me, that goes right to the
heart of the potential fadism
of Black pain and how
when things are no longer
top of mind for people,
it very quickly reverts
to business as usual.
So to your question,
Shawn, what does alliance
look like, I think that
anybody, anybody on the planet--
not just in America.
But anybody on the planet
who views them so or wants
to view themself as an ally of
Black people, people of color,
I think you have to ask
yourself the question,
am I in it for the long haul, or
am I in it for the next month,
or two, or three?
Because the reality
is, as we know,
it's much longer than the
next month, two months, three
months, next year, two
years, three years.
So I think allies
have to ask themselves
the question, the very
hard question, am I down?
How long am I down for?
To what extent am I willing
to negotiate my own humanity
and my own human impulses?
And that's important--
negotiating
one's own human impulses.
Because we as humans,
it is inherently human
that we go on to the next.
We deal with
whatever, but then we
go on to the next that's human.
But I think for anybody who
really wants to be an ally,
I think the question then
becomes to what extent--
how long am I in this for?
Black people don't have
a choice because it's
our everyday reality.
Yes.
For anybody who
wants to be an ally,
I think they have to
challenge themselves
with the question, how
long am I down for?
How long am I in this for?
What am I prepared to do--
And also, what are they--
--in the long term,
over the long haul.
I'm sorry, Gina.
Gina?
Just to coast on this, what
are you willing to give up?
I mean, there's this great
quote that I read, which was,
when you're in a
position of power,
equity feels like oppression.
So when folks
start to feel that,
are they going to be in
there for the long haul,
or are they going to
suddenly realize, oh,
I've got to give up something,
and it's not worth it?
That's where my fear lies.
I feel like we're
getting to that point.
And that article
you just read is
absolutely indicative of that.
Yep, yep.
I don't know.
I think it's a good question
because I find myself wrestling
with it all the time.
And on a little bit more
of an existential level,
that each individual
has to be willing to do
a lot of hard self-analysis.
There has to be a
lot of hard truths
that they have to
face about themselves
and their relationship
to society.
Funny enough, I mean, it's
nothing new by any means.
But for some reason,
Gil Scott-Heron's
"The Revolution Will
Not Be Televised" has
been top of mind for
me lately, very much so
as I wrestle with
my own involvement
and what my
participation looks like,
not just in bettering
our industry.
But what's my own activism and
participation in the world look
like?
But the reason that has
resonance with me is the crux
of what he's saying is it won't
be televised because everyone
has to have a revolution within,
which you cannot capture.
And I feel like the idea of that
is also at the center of what
allyship looks like.
You have to keep pushing
yourself and challenging
yourself to understand
and even get
to the place of participating
in a protest, where you're
participating with empathy,
and you're participating
by opening your ears.
That's leadership
to me is listening.
But that takes someone
who is willing to get over
their own ego, right?
And that's that personal
revolution that has to happen.
And to me, that's fundamental.
Otherwise, that's also how
we continue this cycle.
And also, get fooled by just
bad nonsense news and nonsense
ideas that equity is taking
something away from you.
What the that?
You know?
I actually want to add
something really quickly,
and that is that alliance--
and I'm perhaps
stating the obvious,
and this is very
elementary perhaps.
But alliance, as we know,
can take many forms.
And for those of
us or those of you
who are not comfortable with
marching in the streets,
that's OK.
I think that that's OK.
I think that the question when
one starts to examine oneself,
and as you say, TJ,
challenge oneself to define
for oneself what that alliance
looks like, the potentially
beautiful thing, quote, unquote,
is that I can take many forms,
as long as one is doing
something on an ongoing basis
to enact change.
I would say, TJ and
Gina, all of us,
we may or may not be
marching in the streets,
but we are engaging--
I'm not going to say revolution.
I'm going to say change agents.
We are manifesting
the notion of becoming
living change agents
through our work on one very
fundamental level, each
and every one of us.
That's not marching
in the streets.
I mean, maybe some of us march.
Maybe some of us do not.
But I don't want to--
and I'm sure you do not--
undervalue, underestimate
the power of cinema,
of communication, and
that through our work,
our engaging our work, we are
impacting, frankly, the world.
And I do not believe
that is hyperbole.
I believe it to be true.
I think you're
absolutely right, Delroy.
And I'm sure--
I'm not sure.
But I got a lot of questions
around when the whole unrest
was happening, and people,
allies or wanting to be allies,
asking how can I participate?
What can I do?
What can I learn?
What can I read?
What can I watch?
And it's like, it's not my
history you need to learn.
It's yours.
Mmm.
[LAUGHS]
learn about my history.
I need you to learn
about your history.
I need you to understand
what your part--
and not you specifically.
You weren't around,
but your family's.
I need you to understand
because with that understanding
of your own history comes
what you spoke about, TJ,
which is accountability.
And then, once you
understand what that is,
I need you to go educate
your other friends,
and then I need you
to amplify that.
And that's the power
that you have as an ally.
You have the power
to have those spaces
and have those relationships
that maybe we don't necessarily
have.
But it is your job.
It is your job to
not learn my history.
It's your job to learn yours.
And then it's your job to
not only educate everyone
around you, but to amplify that
message because that message is
where there is change.
And I just wanted to
say to you all here,
thank you all so much for
your participation today.
And to your point, Delroy, the
entire reason for the Academy
Dialogues, again, was because
to have these conversations
centered around filmmaking,
centered around truth,
centered around race
relations, gender equality,
and you are all
affecting the world.
And we are all watching, and we
are all thankful and grateful
for your contribution,
not only as humans, but as
filmmakers to this cinema,
Black cinema, universal cinema,
all cinema because you
guys do all cinema.
Artists, I want to thank
you all so much on behalf
of the Academy for joining
this conversation on Academy
Dialogues.
Listen, one really,
really quick thing.
At the beginning
of this session,
you referred to
myself, TJ, Gina as--
I'm paraphrasing that
you spoke about the fact
that we're all at the
forefront of something.
Did you say that?
It was something like that.
I said affecting.
I want to say I probably
said affecting culture.
Yes, yes, something
along those lines.
And when you said that,
I have to tell you that,
again, internally,
my response was, OK,
I hope I'm affecting culture,
whatever it was that you said.
What I'm aware of--
and now, this is important
as it relates to fadism.
What I'm aware of is it I am
having a moment in my career.
And I'm not being coy.
I'm not trying to
underplay anything.
I'm having a moment
right now specifically,
as it relates to Da 5 Bloods.
And I'm proud of the film.
I'm proud of the moment.
I'm embracing the moment.
But my job-- and
probably for all of us.
My job is, A, to
acknowledge that moment,
to embrace the specialness
of that moment,
and it's beautiful.
It's been beautiful.
It's been extraordinary.
But my job now is
to keep working
and not get caught up in
whatever that moment has been,
may become.
I want to embrace it.
But the larger
responsibility that I have
is to keep working, keep being,
and I think for all of us,
so that one does not
get sucked into fadism.
So that's all.
Good.
100%.
Yeah, for all of us, right?
100%, 100% for all of us.
I mean, just keeping on
is hard enough, right?
It is, man.
I mean, for me, it's
the most important thing
is we won the Oscar
at a really young age.
And you're listening to the
way with which other people are
signing your identity.
And that's a really
slippery slope
to lose track of your own voice.
Because it was early in the
development of even discover--
I'm still trying to figure out
what my voice is, you know?
And that's the part that's
where the work is, right?
That's right.
I want a career, not a
little blip on the timeline--
That's right.
Amen, amen.
--for myself.
Exactly right.
That's exactly right.
Anyhow--
We using all this.
So I love that because
you said your voice,
and knowing that your
voice can change.
You know what I mean?
And you can change--
And should be allowed to change.
Yes.
And your voice should be
allowed to change, as opposed
to being in a box.
Yeah, your voice should
be allowed to change.
Yeah, I heard you speak
a little bit about how
your hesitation towards
the role in Da 5
Bloods initially because he
was a Trump supporter, right?
Yeah.
And how you sat with that for
a little bit and understanding,
oh, that needs to be told too.
And so used your voice
to amplify something
that still needs to be told.
And that story still needs to
be told because that's still
clearly the human experience.
And so your voice can
be allowed to change.
We're all artists.
In any sense of the word,
if you're creating anything,
if you're living in this world,
you are creating something.
You're an artist.
And it's your job involved to
reinvent, to create new space,
to figure out what
the pipeline is,
to create a space where
you're mentoring and bringing
in new people.
But it's your job to
continue finding yourself
because that is your
job to then reflect it
back to everybody else.
Amen.
So true.
Yeah.
Y'all, let's get off
because, clearly,
we would be talking forever.
God bless y'all.
Thank you.
It's been a pleasure, guys.
Thank you for watching
Academy Dialogues.
For more videos, please
subscribe to our channel.